okay ready to get started anyone okay so
welcome everyone this is the Pied in New
York 2017 pop quiz at many PI data
events this year in where do we do it we
did in Seattle we did in Amsterdam we
did one in London I think we skipped one
in Berlin we've done events like this
when we did them after hours at a pub
they were pub quizzes when we did them
during the day they were pop quizzes the
whole idea is a lot of you are a lot of
you are excellent fantastic amazing data
scientist and data engineers some of you
are pretty okay at Python some of you
are great at Python some of you want to
get better at Python we have a guest
emcee today this is Joe Jeff Nick you
may have seen his talk earlier in this
room none of you are as good at Python
as Joe and you will never be as good as
mine tonight so he is a Boy Wonder the
persons of this pop quiz is to have a
little bit of fun learn something about
Python learn something that you didn't
know and answer some questions this is a
completely interactive session the way
it works is I have 48 point five minutes
of questions if we are on schedule time
zones a little bit off but if we're on
schedule we'll end this in 48 point five
minutes you will answer these questions
now I wrote my own custom slide show
program to display this and it has a
couple of features one of them is you
can see how much time you have left the
other one is it blinks really annoyingly
fresh red when you have no time left
so the very first thing I want you to
start with if you're taking notes on a
piece of paper write down your name
since we're not in teams right now write
down your name and your contact email or
Twitter if you're on your laptop just
open up an email you can email me your
answers afterwards if you want to know
what the answers are but what I would
encourage you to do is to actually try
to answer these questions don't just
look at them but actually try and come
up with the answer for them because
it'll really benefit you when we come to
if we have time we'll go over some
answers otherwise it'll be up to you
over the next four days or five days if
you here for Sprint's to come to me or
come to Joe and get the answers now one
thing Joe has been has been recruited
into being our guest emcee for this
within the last two minutes or so so he
knows some of the answers no he knows
every answer he knows every answer to
every question so if you have any
questions about any of this
ask Joe he's seeing them for the first
time but we'll count how long it takes
until he goes oh yeah
I know the answer it's great you know
it's amazing to be young and brilliant
so let's get started
and we're gonna start with a very simple
round it's a round called starting slow
we're gonna ask you some really general
questions about Python and you know if
you don't have your laptop take answers
you know take take take down answers on
your phone but do try to take down
answers at the end of this if you
actually want me to score them you can
email them to me and I'll give you the
actual answers and I'll tell you where
you were right or wrong so number one
starting stuff what's new in Python 3.7
Joe do you know actually something
that's new in Python 3.7 don't share it
with them they're expected to answer
this but do you know something that's
new in Python 3.7 because because I
actually don't know the answer to this
the version number don't put that that's
a dumb answer yeah Joe doesn't even know
something I actually do know something
context Lib dot a sing context manager
nobody knows that oh yeah there you go
next question name three peps their
numbers and what they do for example pep
eight is about how to waste your time
arguing with their co-workers about
formatting so name three other peps and
what they do by number and what they do
I'll give you more than 15 seconds
that's maybe a little bit too little
time will give them for three peps will
give and we give another 20 seconds how
about that chip easy just keep the
answer real short I don't have to be
excepted peps just any pepper yeah for
bonus points use James's pen I'm listed
only in the you in the bottom section in
the acknowledgment so you have to be
really hardcore to read through every
pep all the way to the bottom for extra
bonus points oh yeah there you go
bonus points there that's what people
are looking for in their lives bonus
points and encyclopedic knowledge of
Python proposals
let's move on name three recommendations
from Pep eight that's easy the hard
question would be named three useful
recommendations from jefe I I sent an
email to one of the authors I sent it to
berry Warsaw and I asked him if I can
get a certificate that's a lifetime
exemption for people complaining about
pet bait you know 81 character lines at
my code and he hasn't responded yet but
I'm working on that for 2018 let's give
him another few seconds and then we'll
move on maybe another an extra 30
seconds the 15 seconds yes it is so
that's 45 second in total okay very
simple code question true or false you
know the answer to this true or false
shall we move on
very simple question here true or false
I think 15 seconds is enough for these
anymore and people are gonna fire up
their rebels yeah they'll start they'll
start cheating by actually using the
tools that they use in their day-to-day
job to get real work done how about this
true or false this one's hard
and I promise you there are no typos on
any of these slides except for the ones
where I had typos on them good to go Joe
yeah that's the end of round one so you
can see the format of this quiz is
pretty easy try to answer these
questions there's some benefit to them
we might not have time in this session
to go over all the answers but Joe
myself and a bunch of other people will
be here you can ask them hey I saw this
question do you know the answer it's an
opportunity for you to start a
conversation or free to ask some of the
Python experts who are here at this
event something that might help you
further your understanding let's take a
look at round two now this is a Python
event and many of you know what PI
Python is popular in the world but many
of you don't know where Python the
language or where the inspiration from
some of the terms in the Python language
came from this is an event about Monty
Python
so just to fill things out name three
Monty Python films by the way there is a
prize for the winner of this so whoever
emails me with their answers with the
highest score there is an actual prize
that is worth some considerable amount
of money I think we gave away PI data
tickets before we've done some extra
stuff I think we we might even have we
might have PI data hoodies which are
really cool everyone loves headies those
for sale no those are only for a special
giveaway they're actually on you can't
even buy them in this store
shall we move on were three questions
asked by the bridge keeper you know when
I ask these questions at PI data London
nobody had any idea anything about Monty
Python not a single person in London
they were like months what is that Monty
Python but no this was at a is that an
event with people who are maybe not
Joe's age but my age maybe maybe maybe
it's just maybe it's more popular
outside of the UK three questions asked
by their bridge keeper we haven't quite
warmed up yet they get much harder here
what cheese did the cheese shop actually
have that one's hard
cannot answer any of these yeah Jo
because Monty Python was in the 70s and
you had to either have been alive during
that or had watched it in reruns in the
80s or 90s so this is something where
you need to have some historical
knowledge I'm sure if I asked the
question about brood wars you'd be all
on top of it
that's what's popular with the kids
these days yeah with Andy me with it
yeah
who is that Roddy McDowall that can be
your bonus question who's started
Logan's Run that was a great movie
just-just-just for reaching yeah shall
we move on in one second why not try a
holiday in Sweden this year fill in the
blank do they don't actually know the
answer to this answer it once once the
30 seconds rap we're on the honor system
and it's pop quiz
you don't know any of this did you
phrase your questions in the form of a
question I don't even know just buster
right here okay pencils down this one
it's try the lovely Lakes oh my goodness
you people there yeah there's a moose in
some of these and then finally what's
the difference between an argument and
mere contradiction you may know that one
of the inclusions in Python 3 for
argument clinic was named after a Monty
Python sketch which this question comes
from and sceptered in 3 4 or is it still
pending they've already changed the code
base to reflect the argument clinic
stuff haven't a they did that before was
accepted oh that's you're not supposed
to do that are you yeah okay this guy is
let's take a look around 3 now round 3
is a reminder to us that coming to a PI
data event isn't just about learning
about Python or learning trivia about
Monty Python it's about having fun and
learning people so that's only the first
day but see if you can name three people
you met at this event three new people
just their first names or the guy in the
brown sweater or the girl who works at
Brookhaven National Labs somebody you
met who maybe you uh you enjoyed meeting
because that's what the point of this
event is we give extra bonus points for
that social the social dimension which
should never be forgotten even in the
deepest and densest of code talks why
don't you introduce yourself to the
people around you that's an easy point
we Joe is getting very upset that's not
even a question
nice to meet you Joe I'm glad that you
could be here this is Joe I'm James by
the way nice to meet all of you yeah
this is the this this is the most
important part of the pub it really is
honestly and then there is a question
here are y'all friends yet the only
answer is yes the only answer to this
question is yes it's worth 10 points
let's move on round four everyone makes
mistakes this is one of my favorite
rounds every slide here has a mistake in
it or multiple mistakes find the bugs an
assertion error is a buck so if this
raises an assertion error that's a
mistake notate it I think there might
still be one typo on one of these slides
that also counts as a mistake to find
the bugs some of these have no mistakes
in which case the answer is there are no
bugs and I'll just watch Joe's face
until I can figure out has he got it yet
you got it Wow
I'll let you at the end of this you can
tell me just give him a thumbs up thumbs
down if there are or are not any bugs or
tell them how many bugs you spot it
given the par when the 60 seconds
elapses now find out if I'm right mm-hmm
so just to list the books you found okay
times like how many did you find just
one now there oh yeah there's just one
this one how about this the bug is that
you should not write class methods like
that or methods like this this is all
Python 3 everything in this presentation
is written in Python the presentation
itself is a Python 3 script all of the
code in the presentation is Python 3
Python 3 only then that's a bug in
itself that's and that's honestly that
bug is gonna hurt you more than anything
else that you see at this event yes
I'm just watching his face until he
finds the bugs this one's really hard
I'll give you an extra few seconds on
this this one's really hard this bugs
that are executed or just bugs that
exist in the source both anything that
causes it to not run to termination
without frenzy and error
I'm giving an extra 15 seconds I used to
give people 30 seconds for this one this
is easy you got it you got it oh this
guy how many bikes did you see job -
bugs - bugs
so one last second and see if you can
spot the two bugs and we'll move on okay
how many bugs this is not supposed to be
easy you guys are all Python experts
very highly paid data scientists we can
try we can try oh that's a good that's a
good thing I should one question should
be can you write a line of Python that
is also a valid line of bosch we're
gonna we're gonna add that we're not
that for next year's not me I only
present the question I only present the
questions as possibilities
I only support the system I don't know
why I only contribute to the system I
don't support it
you still haven't found it yet this one
I mean I'm counting its just added a
bunch of operators there yeah is that it
okay how many buddies just like at least
three at least three at least three how
about this one this one's actually not
too bad just requires it you read
through it slowly if Joe enjoys this
session that's enough for me
there's one major major major bug that
many of you won't consider a bug but
it's actually a bug
because that can be worse than can be
worse any other bug I'll let you explain
that to them after the time elapses so
write down your answers and then Joe
will Joe will will show you the books
that you found when you're ready yeah so
the first book that stands out there's a
comment here three sets why it is not an
empty set why it's dictionary so the
comment being wrong is a bug because
that is going to ruin everyone's life
dictionaries don't have an ADD method
and even if they did the value would
probably need to be hashable which
dictionaries are not see any other fun
bugs in here mm-hmm
taking them well you're gonna do a bit
wise for with dictionaries can't do that
can you set Union not the last one
random dot choice cannot be called on
anything that is not a sequence can I
hold on a set yes let's move on if this
one is incredibly confusing but with one
very simple principle it just makes
sense the principle behind this will be
covered in my talk on Thursday namely
how does Python know if a variable as a
local variable or a global variable it
is a very simple principle based on a
very simple execution model that talk is
maybe ten minutes of theory and then
every answer just makes sense this is an
exaggerated example of that at play but
if you see the talk and you understand
how Python works under the covers this
all just makes sense and it's just that
may be exaggerated formulation of that
find as many bugs as you can as many as
you can
I think there's only one don't worry it
gets harder it's harder now I could see
easier from here my goodness you are
taking 90 at the second site I had put
this on jötunn I think there's two bucks
I think there's two bucks yeah where yep
yeah thank you daddy
yeah you doubting yourself that's what
this does that's what the career does it
makes you doubt yourself but you
shouldn't doubt yourself because all of
you are talented programmers and while
this is an artificial example probably
with enough time and just the right
principles I think anyone have you can
get it we'll talk about this more on
Thursday I think this is our second to
last to our last one can anyone spot the
book this is a book that almost all of
you have actually run into in your day
to day lives if you use pandas or numpy
I can see even some of you are nodding
you see it right now and it's a really
stupid error message that doesn't
explain to you what the problem is
actually tells you what what you're
supposed to do but throws you for a loop
and throws you back to trying random
things shake to bugs to tell ya two
bucks and I would say the first one no
no this is this is a bug yeah yeah but
that's that's a balk mm-hmm
no yeah because oh yeah so they're both
I think very important consequences of
how numpy works I mean what do you what
do you consider this just doesn't do
anything interesting but it's not about
okay and then finally for those you know
I always make fun of people who come to
pi/8 events and they ignore all the
wealth of scientific computing and
numeric computing and laser focus on
machine learning and neural networks and
deep learning we are obligated to
include something from scikit-learn
and anything that is done at a PI data
event but let me tell you there's a big
world out there of people doing actual
scientific computing beyond machine
learning that has a lot of interesting
and fantastic stuff exactly exactly if
it doesn't have to do with type
scikit-learn or neural networks
do you know this one somebody if we have
a cycle urn expert they know this one
that's pretty easy which of these models
has a predict prob a method on them
requires you have to have used all the
models though we should add a neural
network question in there yeah yeah you
know one that works real hot everyone
loves them another ten seconds and then
we'll move to the next section very good
I hope some of you are writing down your
answers if you don't have answers that's
okay maybe your score is your name and
your email address that could be enough
you might be the highest one oh this one
is actually come on you run it since
everyone's run into this once the
machine is clock and I lock in pandas
nobody knows except if jeffrey vachs in
the room maybe he knows I don't remember
actually I do but only because I wrote
this question yeah so
that's a that's a reasonable answer it's
a reasonable answer I'll take it I'll
accept it I'll accept it you know all of
these are pieces of code if you fast
type or you can always just type them in
I think this is the last question in
this section and then we get into our
next section so in this section we're
gonna ask you some social questions
about the community how do you pronounce
these things on this on the board now I
will tell you I have met this is an
answer a developer for the top tool that
pronounces it very differently than
another core developer for the top tool
and they hate each other for how they
pronounce it differently but maybe maybe
after this after the 30 seconds are up
we can talk about this no this is just
how do you hardly pronounce mMmmm now
I'll tell you the middle one is actually
pronounced pandas you heard that first
here the fourth one is pronounced
sklearn that is correct yeah how do you
how do you pronounce the last one anyone
got that one the T is silent
TSS how do you pronounce this we are at
PI data which is an event sponsored by
num focus num focus sponsors a lot of
projects all the projects on the
previous screen are either affiliated or
fiscally sponsored projects name three
active num focused project contributors
so three people who make it possible for
you to use the software that you use
every day it's a very important question
I'm gonna spend a little bit more time
on this question because when we take
this pub quiz two pi data events people
realize I use this software every day of
my life and I have no idea how it came
to be so let's take an extra 20 seconds
they just think who are the people who
make it possible for me to do the work
that I do every single day and maybe
beyond the big names beyond West
McKinney or the who are the folks who
are continuing the tradition or
maintaining this software or keeping
this off for a life and if out of this
session he actually he actually has some
commits to some of these projects
otherwise I don't say you're a
contributor but you have commits to
these projects this is also an important
question free at all for you to dwell on
if the only thing that you get out of
this is the answer to this question the
answer the previous question and you met
somebody new
I'll have considered this session a
success but why is numb focus important
one person in one of the quizzes said
it's not and I gave them - 50 points
[Music]
yeah I yeah pretty much I had security
do that why is numb focus importance
very it is a very important organization
not just for PI data but for the
project's themselves this is a serious
question and I think it's worth thinking
for a few seconds 30 seconds of your
time why it's important and maybe
writing it down and including in your
answers okay this is around that people
seem to either love or hate I'm going to
show you some code it'll either be in
Python 2 or Python 3 or it'll work in
both or it'll be a syntax error so it's
either Python 2 Python 3
both or neither okay those are the
possibilities is this Python 2 Python 3
both or neither
now when I say Python 3 I mean the
latest Python 3 when I say Python 2 I
mean the latest python 2 so obviously
this wouldn't work in Python 2.0 Python
2 Python 3 both or neither
give me another a few seconds
Python to Python 3 both or neither well
it's pretty easy you know the answer
confident merged I'll tell you the ones
that do actually works in my interpreter
okay Python to Python 3 both or neither
code might not do anything useful but
sometimes it's useful we have a spot
quickly who what what version do they
write this for Python to Python 3 both
or neither neither of course meaning
syntax error
this is invalid code they added up
pointers to Python but only pointers and
pointers to pointers yeah no further and
only to only to nothing python to Python
3 both or neither it's called a null
pointer okay very good thank you - I
knew I was right and asking you to Co
co-host this session Python to Python 3
both and neither I will give you the
answer to this afterwards do you know
the answer to this Python to Python 3
both or neither only get 15 seconds
because it's very easy to tell
and I believe this is our last example
Python to Python 3 both or neither
got it
oh yeah what's pretty the answer to me
yeah
[Music]
yeah give another a few seconds and then
we'll move to the last and I believe my
favorite section this is hard huh really
hard the other the other take away from
this I suspect is that many of you
realize that python itself is a very
deep language there's a lot of pieces to
it and hopefully this can be an
inspiration for you to dig a little bit
deeper to hone your craft to sharpen the
axe as it were if you have any
co-workers or a code that looks like
that get away yeah we find another job
have you ever written code you've
written code that looks like this I bet
character okay
ripped off my keyboard so oftentimes
when we do this over a two hour session
we self score so that we get through the
answers at the same time unfortunately
this is only a one-hour session so we
don't have a chance to do that you'll
have an opportunity to ask answers for
from Joe or myself or any of the other
experts that we have here over the next
four days anyone know the answer to this
previous question that we looked at
Python to Python 3 both or neither
anyone had an answer for this I want to
show you something very important about
the pop quiz Joe is this Python to
Python 3 both or neither neither these
are tabs these are spaces indentation
error so sometimes the quiz is not fair
and then our final I my favorite round
this round is called the names have been
changed to protect the innocent data
scientists for some reason love to
import things as things you import numpy
as MP you import pandas as PD you import
matplotlib as MPL you even import this
as T let's assume you had a friend or a
co-worker who loved it so much so they
imported everything from every language
as something else
so here's an example of some simple code
that uses the Python standard library
and they've imported everything as
something else in my sample you can kind
of look at it for a few seconds and you
might be able to guess what was what
everything's from a standard library we
can see
oh you're unpacking two things here and
then there's two things in here and
there's a function here this function
takes a start parameter what do you
think that must be it's from the
standard library hey yeah what a is
enumerate what do you think the Who am I
is if it's taking these two and if a as
a numerator dip and what do you think
the B probably is something simple print
so the answer for this would be somebody
did have from built-ins import enumerate
as a from built-ins and numerate print
as be from built-ins enumerate sip as
Who am I I think that if you import
anything as anything you're I don't like
that at all in any case the answer to
this is these and also what the actual
library is if you struggle to figure out
what the pieces are then for partial
credit and for a significant amount of
the partial credit just tell us what the
library is here the library would be
built-ins
so what library is this by the way all
of these have been taken from the
standard documentation from the project
so what what library is this and if you
can guess what the Who am I one is and
what the Who am I to us this is an
example that you will see on the website
for that package as one of their stock
examples and all I've done is change the
names to protect the innocent and see if
you can guess what the Who am I one and
two are and what project it is can you
guess library yes Who am I to
close close but no cigar
this is a big hint though these are the
hint is right here have fun how about
this one what libraries this and what's
the Who am I there's only one yeah so
this shows that if you randomly import
things under other names people can
still kind of figure out what the code
is like that puzzle that was going
around where you swapped the letters
inside the words and see if people can
still read them please yeah please don't
ever import numpy as MP I hate that
that's yeah what's the alternative
import all the names yes no yes then I'm
gonna see some which some is that is
that NP dot some is that song it's no
then take from dump I import some yes
but so much shadows a built in then
imported as something out some other
name but I can't use import as because
no you can you can't do it at the module
level yeah yeah okay he says they
corrected he's the quiz master so there
we go what library is this what library
is this and what's the Who am I
pretty straightforward you really like
split as a method I'm used in a few
examples I like split so useful string
method strings are the fundamental data
type no white strings are the
fundamental data target the dictionaries
fundamental data type mm-hmm every
language has white strings no not really
but I might you know you know what I'm
getting at yeah you know I get the
general flavor of the idea the flavor
exactly don't undermine me when we're on
stage together let's move on what
library and what's the Who am I oh
there's there's a big hint well you have
to know a little bit about science to
figure out what this is go learn some
science Joe
I believe the next one is our last
question I know we have formal just one
library I mean there's the built-ins are
used as well but just one library here
The Who am I is a little bit tricky it's
one of those one of those functions from
that library actually no there are two
kind of two libraries used that's a very
good thing that you spot this is our
second to last question I'm sure some of
you have seen this library before I can
guess what it might be every one of
these has a big hint yeah at least you
knew what though at least you knew the
last library if you didn't know the last
Who am I this one's so easy dan you know
which library this is there's a big hint
look at this or that that enough not
enough give you another 15 seconds then
we'll go to our last question everyone
will get the last question we try and
throw in some gimme points in here other
than your name and our last question of
the New York PI did in New York 2017 pop
quiz what library is this and what met
the name is that and as per instructions
for those of you who have been writing
down your answers on your phones or your
your laptops send me an email my name is
James at Numb focus orgs my email
address have James Powell send me an
email make the title
pop quiz answers I'll tell you your
score if you had the highest score I
think what we were gonna give the
highest scoring person was a free ticket
to PI data next year and if we have any
hoodies leftover one of the num focus
hoodies that currently only go to
project contributors and key notes I
think
have some extra left over that we will
have for you as well as a big prize
involved they are really comfortable
really soft and they tell the world how
you feel about free software open-source
software
so all together let's say what this
library is everyone oh this library is
learn exactly you always have to include
a scikit-learn question no matter what
the material is thank you so much this
has been the pop quiz I hope you enjoyed
it
send me your answers James and I'm
focused on org any questions you have
you can ask either one of us we know all
the answers thank you
[Applause]